see but he'd showed some very What I
Call Accurate
um weapons
so he's quite what I call a sharp
teacher he'd be working like sharp in
Idaho
positions
what you're doing is once you get off
here
watch my arm a lot of you are coming up
that means he's got as much chance to
leave on you as you leaning on him and
pushing you away are you not answering
and so what turned his own problem was
I go that way I go across there I don't
I don't go around this way around so
there's too much for you to remember but
and I said about cutting this way and
turn the hips that way I said I'm I'm
doing two things and I need to only do
one if I'm going to go in that direction
I'll be doing that I'll go ahead and
insert this Direction doing that so this
is the same here's cut dead straight he
turns for a dead straight cut again just
because he turned means the straight
cuts are straight so if I do my arm like
that like that under the circle while
he's doing a stride
so it's not the rock scissors
so look he's there
if I line up with his body it would be
there oh I'm here when he comes up I I
come up straight that way and I have a
few tries to cut I'm I'm now in the
center
I let him go past
like
first of all gimmer that they'll tug on
the collar with my hip power followed by
the thrust with the back hip and this
to here that's not so important
everybody wants to throw the importance
is you're coming circular and you need
to come straight